Bob: Sean is
Mark: Fuuuuck...
Wade: I'm level 77!
Mark: WOOOW
Jack: Who's Sean?
Mark: Huh, Sean??
Mark: *laughter* The fffffuck?
Jack: Seeeannnn duude Bob: I mean, uh, Jeff
Mark: Je-he-he-he-heff
Sean: Mah nam ah Jeef!
Mark: Mah nam ah Jeef??
Sean: MAHNAM AHZ JEEF--mahnam Peepsi
Mark: Mahnamb ehh jeef I like Pepis
Mark: MMMM
* giggles*
Jack: Would you like a nice cold Pepis?
*Mark giggles*
*Bob giggles*
Mark: Ah fuck
Wade: I hope you guys aren't recording anymore (Bob: Oh my God)
Jack: (Borat accent) Pepis change world
Mark: I-da quote nothing.
Mark: I got Pepis, Pepis, stop protest
Jack: (TF2 Heavy accent) U want protest, bring PEPIS!
Mark: Ey, cop, you want a Pepis?
Mark: HHHMMMM
Jack: (Heavy) EVERYBODY FRIEND WITH PEPIS!
Everybody: *Laughing*
Jack: (Heavy) Nobody fight with Pepis
Mark and Bob: *laughing*
Mark: Ah fuck..
Jack: (normal voice) We try to keep up on your current pop culture shit storms (Bob: Oh shit..)
Mark: Yeah
Wade: Fuck
Jack: (Heavy) Nobody get kicked off United Airline with Pepis
Mark: La pickle
Mark: Hitler never had Pepis, he never did *everyone laughing*
Jack: (Heavy) Hitler never used Pepis
Mark: (accent) Never on your life!
Jack: (Heavy) Everyone happy on Passover with Pepis!
*Bob laughing loudly*
Wade: I think you guys broke Bob! (Mark: Ahh man) (Bob: Ahh fuck)
Wade: I'm no good with Tracer, I can guarantee that--I can probably Mercy... Maybe?
Mark: I'll do... I'll do what I can
Sean: You can be Reinhardt, Reinhardt...
Bob: Do what you can't Mark.
Mark: Okay, that's...
Wade: Wanna be our healer, Mark?
Mark: I'll be the healer! I love being healer
Bob: a'ight (alright)
Mark: I'll do that
Wade: So Bob will Trace
Jack: We have Torb, Tracer, Reinhart and...
Wade: Oh, do we have to wa... we should prob... do you wanna watch this?
Mark: Hey! I haven't seen it
Wade: Yeah
Mark: Nooo
Jack: (British accent) 50 years ago, London was full of fucking robots, innit? But then the Fire Nation attacked
Bob: *laughs*
Mark: NOOOOOO
Mark: I'm not gonna skip, guys
Bob: *very bad British accent* Are you from England?
Jack: It's like they were trying to dig their own grave
(Game keeps talking) launched a surprise attack
Jack: Then the Fire Nation attacked
Mark: Ha. Heh heh.
Wade and Bob: HAHA!
Bob: It's like that Michael Cameron movie
Mark: Ah
Jack: No human! I will protect thee!
Mark: Oh jeez
Jack: Check out my robo ass
Wade:  He's wearing khakis like me
Mark: Yeah, why is he wearing clothes?
Bob: Those are not cargo shorts
Mark: That's a big question
Bob: Because it's gross to be naked, duh
Mark: Alright, do they have a robot penis that they're trying to hide or something?
Jack: I hope so
Bob: How do you think they make robot babies?
Mark: I don't know (Jack: Ro-babies)
Mark: Can you explain it to me? (Bob: Yeah, Ro-babies) (Jack: Rabies)
Bob: That's what I was gonna say
Mark: Rabies??
Mark: HOW DO YOU THINK THEY MAKE RAAAABIES??
*laughter*
Bob: Aww what a sweet rabie
Mark: *Laughing* (Jack: Come on, for God's sake!)
Mark: Help me, (*Nasally* Help me)
Jack: You got a cute little hat though (Mark: Thank you)
Bob: I got a cute little hat too
Mark: I got cute little other things too (Bob: D-Don't forget about my hat)
Mark: Yeah
Jack: We're all friends here (Wade: Woohoo)
Jack: Somebody has to stay in there
Bob: Not me (Mark: I'm here)
Jack: I can go in, I got a turret
Bob: I'm gonna go out here and if I start to die I'm gonna blame you Mark
Mark: Okay, alright then I'll stay here
Mark: And doing the thing with the thing (Jack: Reinhardt!)
Jack: Ahhwoo (Mark: Reinhardt)
Mark: I'm being killed
Mark: It's horrible (Wade: What difficulty are we doing-
Wade: -this on by the way) Bob: This is just normal
Bob: Mark can you umm?, thanks buddy (Wade: Ohhh, boringly eaaasy)
Mark: I got you (Jack: No this-
-Jack: this gets pretty hard)
Bob: Yeah we'll see, we'll see if we actually do it
*Laughter*
Mark: Is this actually, difficult? (Wade: I beat this on expert-
-Wade: Yesterday)  Mark: oOoOo Bob: WTF really?
Wade: Yep (Bob: You did not)
Wade: Yeah, no we did uh.. we didn't do it
Wade: With these characters though
Bob: Oh well like any character doesn't really fucking count (Jack: Oh well that doesn't fucking count)
Mark: Ha (Wade: Yes it does)
Bob: We had a Bastion and Orisa and a Mercy and also a 76 and we beat it on expert
Wade: Actually I think that was our exact team makeup
Bob: Yeah well cause that's the fucking optimal comp duh
Jack: You just get a fucking d.va bomb and it kills everything
Bob: Ha. Yea
*bob short giggles*
Bob: I like how I'm debating strategy like I know anything about this game
Mark: Yeah, um, I believed you, you sounded like you knew what you were talking about
Bob: Right?
Bob: Hey Hey. can yo- can you left click me?
Bob: Noooo! Not him!
Mark: Wait what?
Mark: Sorry
Bob: Oh thanks
Mark: W-you had like 2 damage done
Bob: I only have 150 health, man
That's a lot of damage for me
Mark: Get some armor then
Jack (mockingly): "I only have 150 health"
Bob: Hey, who's not puttin down armor?
Jack: I have the armor!
Bob: Oh, thanks
Jack: see? If you're NICE you get the armor..you fuck
Bob: Oh, thanks buddy...you fuck
Jack: Come get yer armor
Mark: Don't ult and then stand on it
Wade: I'm here for the armor
Mark: Don't do that
Bob: Ye salty dogs
Jack (laughing): "Ye salty dogs" Torm doesn't say that!
*Mark laughs* Bob: Sure he does
Jack (pirate voice): Com'ere ye salty dogs!
Bob: It's a common Scandinavian saying, I'm pretty sure
Mark: Yeah
Bob: Ye salty dogs!
Mark: I've heard my-my Scandinavian neighbor say that one time
Bob: Yeah, definitely
Mark: Yeah, I heard that
Wade: Wait, your neighbor is Torbjörn? Mark: Yeah
Jack: Well, the Scandinavians do love salt, so..
Mark: Yeah, that's what I said
Wade:  Well there's no one on the point
Wade: No one's on the point
Bob: Oh, That's important
Mark: Wade's fault
Mark: Why do I gotta be on the point?
Mark: You guys all suck
All: You hear the attack
Bob: You're just the healer.
Mark: I can do damage, you guys want me to do gun only? (Wade: Uh, Bye)
I can do- I can do gun only mercy. (Jack: Laters)
Bob: Gun only mercy?
Mark: Yeah, attack mercy is gonna be super sweet, you guys are gonna see it, it's gonna be awesome.
Wade: He got in the meta?
Bob: Yeah, it's the new meta "Attack Mercy".
Mark: Yeah I'm aware I'm aware
Bob: I said it first, meta
Wade: Meta
Jack: Meta tank
Jack: Tank Meta
Wade: Meta
Mark: Meta Meta Meta
Jack: MEDIC!
Jack: Let me here those guns
Mark: Let me hear those metas
Bob: You could shoot flying fuckers out of the sky its really satisfying
Mark: Yeah
Wade: Come get yer salty dogs
Wade:  Aw- Screw you one eyed penis robots.
Jack: Just spam alt cause you get-
Bob: Penis... robots, really?
Mark: Spam alts like this? Heroes- ah I can't do it, heroes are not dead.
Jack: Yeah, you're not allowed
Mark: I'm having fun to guys! I'm having- I've had a lot of fun.
Mark: This is great.
Bob: Are you having the healist fun you've ever had?
Jack: Are you having a meta time dude?
Mark: Oh yeah, the best.
Bob: Hey, Ryan Heart, this detonator. Hey, Ryan Heart, hey Ryan heart! He- oh nice
Bob: Oh, nice. Oh- god!
Jack: I played with a winston that- like, primal raged it right into the payload and it exploaded.
Bob: *Laughs oddly*
Jack: It was so fuckin dumb.
Bob: Oh, I pulsed him right in his bum.
Mark: I wish I had a pulse, that'd be nice...
Bob: How's it going Mark?
Mark: I'm having FUN, yeah...
Mark: I've got this on lock guys, shooting with my pistol.
Mark: You guys seen my pistol? It's pretty good, it's got 20 rounds.
Mark: Can shoot headshots- It's pretty good.
Wade: whUUoo! Bastian!
Jack: Normal mode? Ha- more like shmormle-mode
Bob: More like EASY mode!
Wade: More like, not hard!
Mark: Yeah guys, this is real easy... yeah.
Wade: Is Bastian on the right?
Bob: You having a good time, Mark?
Mark: Yeah, no, it's good...
Bob: I keep forgetting I need to check in with you.
Mark: Yeah, nah, it's oK. You know I realize, I realize that-
Bob: Hey, we did it! good job everybody.
Mark: Yeah, I was here on the thing-
Bob: Normal job, everyone.
Mark: Yeah mm pretty good.
Jack: Come get yer- er
Wade: I appreciate that, Markimercy.
Jack: They're making a chicken out of a-
Bob: Come get yer dogs, you salty harbor.
Bob: I feel like i'm getting closer to the truth with that. *Mark giggles*
Bob: With that voiceline.
Mark: That's just a great line in general.
Mark: "I feel like I'm getting closer to the truth."
Bob: *giggles* Jack: What about a regular reaper voice?
Bob: You can shots out of the way Wade!
Wade: What? Mark: Woooooooooow Bob: Or you can miss thats fine
Mark: Wade Ima- I don't think you deserve this damage boost anymore how about give it back to Bob
Wade: I- I didn't, I didn't do that! (Bob laughs loudly)
Mark: Yeah we saw you didn't do that, yeah you didn't
Wade: oaubsd the right!
Jack: Thats the problem you didn't do it!
Mark: Yeah you really didn't Bob: You definitely did not-
Wade: Going right of your taget is the new meta
Mark: Seems to be a bit of a problem with a lot of dogs back here (Wade: NO)
Jack: Yeah, If only some sort of like-
Bob: Whadya- Why do you call them penis things?
Wade: I don't know!
Bob: They look like little dogs or velociraptors, they did not look like penises.
Mark: No actually- yeah they're in no way a penis.
Mark: Bob you wanna heal? I got ya. I got ya, baby
Bob: Oh, thanks bro!
Mark: I gotcha, baby!
Jack: Fuck her up! Oh wait- ya gotta- ya gotta stand near her at the end cuz you get to be in the ?
Mark: No I'm not- I'm there guys, I swear!
Mark: There I am!
Bob: Oh hey Mark! What's up buddy?
Wade: *wooooing*
*Bob laughing* Mark: Yeah I was there guys the whole time.
Mark: Did you notice me? Helping?
Bob: Yeah, good job, man!
Mark: Thanks.
Mark: Thanks guys.
Bob: Good job.
Bob: Point of that game
Wade: BOOPY DOOPY?!
Bob: Boopi Doopi.
Jack: But look at my photographs.
Bob: I am a SALTY DOG.
Mark: ARGH molten core armor heree
Jack: I went all over them.
Mark: MMM
Bob: Wow.
Wade: molten armor?
Jack: Why does the- he doesn't sound anything like a Swedish person.
Bob: He doesn't sound- *laughs* He sounds like a Swedish pirate person.
Mark: I-I
Jack: *indistinguishable* I feel bad for him- *laughs*
Mark: I had nine percent kill participation, guys!
Mark: I had nine percent, I hope you know that! Bob, Jack, Wade: there you go *laughing*
Bob: Oh look how special you are, Mark!
Mark: I- I feel special guys! I feel good!
Wade: Your nine percent kill participation was outstanding.
Mark: I feel good, yeah, I feel good guys! Nice.
Bob: I thought you were gonna say it was, "Out of this world."
Mark: Aw man...
Bob: I'm gonna rate that match a plus.
Mark: I'm gonna give that also a plus.
Bob: That's a serious plus.
Mark: That was major plussage.
Bob: That was plus as fuck right now.
Bob: Alright so do we wanna try that but harder?
Bob: Or do we wanna try any hero we wanna-?
J: Any Hero
M: Hardest mode, any hero
M: I'll be Mercy... again
B:*laughing*